as far as the common agricultural policy
is concerned, that was one of today's
main topics we have set ourselves this goal with
the common agricultural policy of the
union, which we
discussed for an extremely long time in today's council meeting
,
commissioner phil hogan is
particularly interested in the aspects of
simplification and  of subsidiarity
for the presidency of the council there is
no doubt that the reform of the
common agricultural policy is very high
on the eu agenda and should of
course also be seen in connection with the
multiannual financial framework of the union.
another topic was
conditionality at the request of the
finnish delegation  was advised
on unbureaucratic implementation
of the environmental performance, i.e.
conditionality, the
member states are primarily
concerned with simple and effective implementation
and a stronger and
stronger incentive component for
farmers discontinued is that costs
cash f  low